Thing about free speech is that like I'm
not a free speech advocate.
Let's say I'm a true speech advocate,
which is to say that I believe that
people should say what they believe to
be true.
I think that's.
That's your obligation.
It's also you're right,
but it comes with an obligation,
but I don't believe that true speech as
possible without free speech because
you're just not very good at thinking
and so you have to stumble around when
you were first formulating ideas and
wander into territory that's not
necessarily productive and manifest your
biases and in short you have to be a
fool and the only way that you you
improve upon that performances by well
first of all,
stumbling through it to begin with and
then second,
by observing carefully what sort of
reactions you're getting and having a
dialogue around it so that you can start
to sharpen up your ideas and improve
their focus and find out where you've
made a mistake and all of those things.
So a lot of what's necessary with
regards to thinking is the freedom to
make mistakes because what are you going
to do it right the first time?
I don't think so.
And you know,
that's why for Carl Young,
for example,
the fool was a mythological precursor to
the,
to the hero,
the tricksters and mythological
precursor to the hero.
Because unless you're willing to stumble
around badly to begin with,
you know,
and to be a fool when you first start
doing something which is always the case
when you're learning something new,
then you're not going to make any
progress.
And so practically speaking,
free speech has to be as untrammeled as
possible so that people can be wrong and
they can be biased and they can still
express their opinions including their
darker ones and then allow themselves to
be subject partly to improvement by the
world.
Because if you say things that are too
stupid and then act the mouth,
the world's smacks you a good one.
But there's also the social
intermediaries,
the other people that you're
communicating with who will also do the
same thing.
You know,
and we're always broadcasting
information at each other,
constantly trying to shape each other's
behavior and what we're trying to do is
to bring forth from other people that
which we would like to see them
manifest.
And so there's an implicit ideal as well
that people are broadcasting at each
other all the time and there's
tremendous social pressure generally
speaking,
to manifest that implicit ideal as
closely as possible because otherwise
people disapprove of you or lack
interest in what you're saying or
criticize you or and so on.
And you have to be allowed to be exposed
to that kind of corrective feedback
because otherwise you drift and,
and you'll become subject to your own
idiosyncratic insanity.
And I mean,
I,
I've seen that very many times in my
clinical practice because,
well,
first of all,
I have some isolated people that come to
see me and all they do is talk.
I just listen.
I mean because they don't have anyone
else around and they need someone to run
their narrative by,
to keep their minds organized.
They can't do it themselves and they
can't do it without listening to
themselves talk.
Even because for most people talking is
how they think and,
and talking socially is even more how
they think.
And I mean that literally.
I don't mean that metaphorically is
that,
and I think that's true for almost
everyone,
you know,
I mean there are people who are trained
academically who can actually think,
but to think you have to divide yourself
into subpersonalities I suppose each of
which has a differing opinion,
uh,
well elucidated differing opinion.
And then you have to let those different
elements of your personality have an
internal dialogue and you have to draw
conclusions from that.
It's very,
very difficult for people to do that.
And we radically overestimate the degree
to which they do.
Um,
young said at one point that people
don't think so much is as thoughts
appear in their head and they believe
that the,
which I think is a much more accurate
way of describing the,
the general.
Because true thought is not only that
the thoughts arise in your mind,
it's that you look at the thought and
then you critique it,
right?
You have to separate yourself from the
thought and decide whether or not it's
valuable.
Now it's more like an editing function
and you know,
it takes a long time to be a good
editor,
a tremendous amount of time and it just
doesn't happen.
Generally speaking so well.
So I would say,
well,
without free speech there's no true
thought.
And then you might say,
well,
who the hell cares whether or not we
think,
and I think the answer to that is fairly
straightforward.
I mean,
you might think it's so obvious that it
doesn't need explanation,
but there are very few things that are
so obvious they don't need explanation.
So the reason you think is so that the
world doesn't smack you as hard as it
might fundamentally,
you know,
and,
and I really mean this technically
because the way that people evolved the
capacity to thought for thought was that
the prefrontal cortex which mediates a
lot of,
of,
of voluntary linguistic ability actually
emerged over the course of evolutionary
history out of the motor cortex.
And so that's a very interesting thing
to understand because it means that,
you know,
animals basically think by moving and
the problem with that is if you think by
moving and you make the wrong move,
then your dad,
whereas what human beings can do is they
can generate fictional avatars of
themselves in fictional worlds and they
can run the avatars as simulations and
the ones that get killed,
they don't express in behavior.
And I mean you could do that with words
too,
although people know originally would
have done it mostly with images.
They do the same thing with drama.
And so the reason that you think,
and I think it was George,
was it Alfred North Whitehead that said
this,
I think,
but I'm not absolutely sure.
The reason you think is so that your
thoughts can die instead of you.
And that's a brilliant,
so brilliant,
brilliant phrase and absolutely the
case.
So if you think properly,
then you kill off.
The idea is that if you act it out would
kill you or at least cause you suffering
or perhaps caused suffering to the
people around you.
And since it's more or less obvious,
a priority,
that suffering is worse than not
suffering under most circumstances,
it seems reasonable to act in a manner
that will minimize it to the degree that
that's possible.
And so you need clarity of thought
because that helps guide you through a
world that's in shrouded in fog and full
of sharp objects.
And if you don't want to stumble into
them and impale yourself,
then you should have sharp vision and
sharp capacity to communicate.
You know,
that's one of the things I tell students
when I'm trying to teach them to write
because they had no one ever tells them
why they should learn to write.
It's like you learn to write so you can
think and you learn to think so that the
world doesn't treat you any more harshly
than it absolutely has to.
And that's no joke.
You know?
And if you,
if you're a person who's been around a
bit,
you see very rapidly that people who
sharpen their arguments properly and can
articulate their position and defendant
are always,
always the people who are most
successful and most compelling.
And that.
And that changed the way structures
function and and that also helped things
continue in the proper path when they're
running down the proper path.
It's no joke to be articulate and to be
able to think there isn't anything
that's more powerful than that.